m
[Musique]
lui c'est dr mollard connu sous le nom
de michel 6 ness voilà déjà 25 ans que
l'otorhinolaryngologie sts le plus
célèbre de france est devenu animateur
télé comme stéphane plaza passé d'agent
immobilier animateurs comme philippe
etchebest passé de cuisinier à
animateurs ou encore matthieu delormeau
assez d'analystes financiers ah bon
c'est un mauvais exemple
si pour ces consultations michel siemens
affiche complet en télévision c'est une
autre paire de manches
je me suis procuré l'électrocardiogramme
des audiences de ces dernières émissions
si le corps humain a des pouvoirs
extraordinaires
il ne semble pas avoir le pouvoir de
regarder ses émissions
michel cymes est un touche à tout comme
jean michel mr docteur présentateur
comédiens ont pied ou encore humoristes
si ce que michael jackson ne pouvait
mettre sa prothèse tout seul et je cite
qui lui tenait le pénis peut-être pour
ça qu'ils ont écrite beat it
alors michel cymes at-il plus de passion
que de téléspectateurs le docteur cymes
utilise-t-il désormais son stéthoscope
comme cyril hanouna lui a préconisé
continue à prendre ton stéthoscope et
menchov
[Musique]
et surtout michel cymes va-t-il bientôt
se faire piquer sa place de médecin le
plus célèbre de france
allô docteurs mohamed benyamna plus
connu sous le nom de bouder
autant de questions auxquelles
l'inspecteur baba va tenter d imposer l
enquête de baba on se moque de ma que tu
le prends très bien où tout le monde
alors les chéris voilà donc les
audiences c'est vrai qu'il a failli être
battu n'est pas loin de france 5 hier
voilà les autres soit 6 millions cette
france 3 tf1 3 millions la france a
renoncé à 23 millions mais c'est vrai
que c'est quand même compliqué voilà les
hommes de michel cymes pourquoi michel
cymes
même si on dit c'est vrai on dit que
c'est l'animateur préféré des français
et pourquoi c'est arrivé
il fait pas beaucoup d'audience est-ce
que vous avez une analyse non mission
rigoler dassault est sénateur quoi pour
faut qu'il ait pas dit matters est pas
mauvais les gens l'adorent
les gens adorent vrai sondage et quand
tu peux division il fait des scores pour
il ya un problème
ah ben c'est quoi le problème alors
castaldi qui est un professionnel de la
télé mais je pense que je pense que ces
émissions m'intéresse pas je pense que
lui contrairement à qui les gens pensent
n'est pas sympathique
honnêtement confirmé les gens l'adorent
vallée d'andorre mais il n'avait pas su
de son émission qu'il n'aime pas il ya
un rejet hassi ba non quelqu'un à
regarder son émission alo et inversement
moi je me rappelle l'époque marc olivier
fogiel il était toujours dans les
animateurs les moins aimés elle s'était
lui qu'on regarde et plus et c'est vrai
donc voilà donc serré qui a pas de
corrélation entre l'amour ou peut avoir
pour un animateur et le fait de faire
des grosses audiences oui à la mode
c'est à dire deux choses je réponds pour
moi la l'apogée du melon c'est quand les
gens boycottent des émissions des
chaînes dans lesquelles ils sont pas
invités mais ces gens très très drôle et
je n'irai jamais la personne a invité
bon voisinage at à aiguille fayssac tous
ceux qui le critiquent après je crois
mais justement c'est fogel qui me
laissait une fois il m'avait dit les
téléspectateurs n'analyse pas la télé
mais ressemble des choses à la
télévision c'est un état c'est un média
de 2,2 de sensations et je trouve moi
quand je le regarde qui dégage de lui
quelque chose d'extrêmement antipathique
je crois que ça commence à se voir
véritablement dans les sondages qui sort
toujours très très faible a peut-être
une école faisait cotiser de la médecine
je pense que les gens aimaient bien
c'est un médecin sympathique et
maintenant il se veut plus médecins il
se veut animateur il en a pris
malheureusement tout le tout les mots
tous les mauvais côtés de l'animateur
c'est à dire un peu l'égo je me mets en
avant je parle que de moi je fais des
vannes j'interviewe les gens mais je
m'intéresse qu'à la cama question est
pas la réponse
et maintenant il a le mauvais côtés de
l'animateur géraldine après moi je vous
trouve dur il faut voir qu'il fait des
émissions sur le service public sans
prime time sur la centenaire si la même
thématique un fonctionnaire non mais
pardon c'est ma machine s'est pas non
alors j'avais des cartons mais ça
contient on fasse une mare d'eau
marien les vacances pardon alors j'ai
très bien joué mais ça marchait pas en
prime time
si la marche et si ça fait c'est déjà le
dit non mais ça oui mais quand il était
vous savez quand il était sur france 5
avec me rien en cause là ça va ça
fonctionnait bonne marche très bien ça
marche toujours
moi je pense que quand même c'est des
sujets qui sont pas forcément fédérateur
en prime time pour l'aménagement michel
vachon beaucoup dans les sondages parce
que s'il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
répondait les votes des femmes comptent
énormément sur l'âge et le fantasme du
médecin de sable houchin près certain
prestige médecins en plus un peu drôle
en plus un vrai sac un peu sexy c'est
vrai ça du coup tout de suite ça donne
comme tout mais quand on était dans
l'urgence c'est de notre futur statut
dans sa conquête pour lui mais en fait
quand tu regardes frémissons séchante
usap
c'est vrai c'est vrai il est souvent des
choses intelligentes c'est vrai mais oui
mais c'est j'ambitionnais rien sonné
merci oui c'est que le pouvoir
sanguinaire du corps humain ça existe
depuis plusieurs années et que
l'émission le thème d'hier soir il avait
déjà été traité deux ou trois fois moins
cher et autres biens dans la même
émission ça fait plein de bon sens qu'il
ya des gens qui sont lissés sa demande
et ont engrangé des profits aussi une
explication